[موسيقى]
احنا النهارده
الناس مثلا الشباب الصغير اللي المفروض
اسرع منك
كثير مني ومنك ماشي دول
ايه اللي خلاه يقعد يتفرج على
الحلقه ساعه
المنطق بيقول لو مش هنا المنطق السوري
يعني اللي هو كانه واحد زائد واحد يساوي
اثنين وخلاص لا ممكن جدا يبقى المنطق
السوري يقول لك انك انت المفروض الشباب ده
عايز يتفرج علي خمس دقائق عشر دقائق
لانه انه يقول لك بدل بعد اتفرج على حلقات
كثير انا ضمه واتفرج عليه مثلا ثلاث اربع
خمس حلقات
وبشرط وبرفعه على الموبايل
بتاعك
صحيح
ومسريا عن الناس
[موسيقى]
مقولتش انا مش ندمان على اي دور انا عملته
مهما كان الدور ومهما كان الفيلم وبالذات
اوبيان وفي الفيل الازرق وفي الجزيره دي
اعمال عملت لي خطوات لو انكرتها كاني بنكر
كل اللي انا عملته هذه هي الاعمده اللي
بدات عليها
غير عادي انا بقولته بس اللي قلته انه
فعلا لو انا النهارده عرض علي الدور ده مش
هاعمله يعني هذا دور امتحان تقوم به وانت
على الحروق همم اسمك مكتوب بالرصاص بعد
ولم تتثبت في المهنه ادور انتحاريه بالذات
انما قاعده افكر النهارده لو انا عندي
الجمهور ده الحمد لله والبتاع ايه اللي
يخليني خاطر بدور همم زي ده او ايه اللي
يخليني اخاطر في الحته دي بالذات واحنا في
المجتمع ده
[موسيقى]